[MUSIC PLAYING]
Wouldn't it be great
if you could simply
copy something from the
web with a single click?
No more mousing over
text, then right clicking,
and then clicking again to copy.
Chrome 43 lets you
do it with one click.
We've also moved DOM objects
to the prototype chain
to improve compatibility
across the web.
As a bonus, you
can now use WebMIDI
to create great music in
the browser without a flag.
These are just some of
the new developer features
available to you in Chrome 43.
Let's take a look at
what's new in Chrome.
Using the selection API to
programmatically select text
and document dot
execCommand copy,
or document dot
execCommand cut, we
can make cutting or copying
text as easy as a single click.
Then, once it's on
the clipboard we
can clear the selection with
window dot getSelection dot
removeAllRanges.
Check out Matt Gaunt's post
about cut and copy commands
on HTML5 Rocks for
all the details,
and let me know in
the comments if you've
added it to your site.
To help improve
compatibility across the web,
DOM attributes have moved
to the prototype chain.
For many web developers, this
won't make any difference.
But if you're using
hasOwnProperty on DOM objects
or using object dot
getOwnPropertyDescriptor on DOM
objects or serializing
DOM objects with JSON dot
stringify, you should
double check that things
are working as expected.
This brings Chrome more
in line with the web
IDL spec and other
browers' implementations,
such as Internet
Explorer and Firefox.
It also increases the
hackability of DOM programming,
making it easier to
implement polyfills
that efficiently emulate
functionality that's
missing in some browsers.
Paul Kinlan has the
details spelled out
in this HTML Rocks article.
Finally, Chrome 43 allows you
to connect many common music
instruments and controllers
to your browser,
from keyboards and
DJ decks and mixers
to drum pads and FX
units with WebMIDI.
Together with Web
Audio, it's now
possible to build complete
music production applications
on the web and control
virtual web instruments
with real controllers.
Remember Jam with Chrome
or the Moog Doodle
from a couple years ago?
Well, now they can
be made playable
with a musical keyboard
instead of a mouse.
These are just a few
of the new features
for developers in Chrome 43.
Thanks for watching and be
sure to subscribe to the Google
Developer channel.
As soon as Chrome
44 is released,
we'll be right here to tell
you what's new in Chrome.
[MUSIC PLAYING]